I feel like the internet needs some basic rules of engagement
making tens of thousands of people think that you are in a crisis situation
or you or your children's life might be in state
because your husband is going through a mental health crisis
when in reality you're just telling a story about what happened a few months ago
because you want this to go out
you know to as many people as possible to raise awareness and help
it really rubs me the wrong way
it's obviously not the worst thing that someone has done for clicks and views
however it's really difficult to watch people continuously cross boundaries of
like what is normal
rational and sane just for a platform
just for some views it's getting really frustrating to watch
just like lack of basic fucking decorum
like I understand that the situation that happened to you
and you wanted to paint the picture right
but like you have said hey
story time right
like this is what happened a few months ago
making it seem as if you are currently in an abusive situation with a man
where there is potential for like
life threatening issues and like
lives at risk for the sake of a better story is weird and wrong
and you should not have done that
I wish people in general reevaluated the way they act on the internet
and reevaluated their own like
moral limits on the internet
just like in general I I think that we are really losing the fucking plot
and losing how to interact with basic human decency on the internet
and we are forgetting like the impact of what we do in the name of going viral
in the name of you know
getting some money in the name of
you know getting some followers
the internet is like a public town square right
like it works the best when we are just being basically decent human beings
and making tens of thousands of people think that
you are currently actively in danger
life threatening danger is not cool
please reevaluate